this is what lockdown looks like in
Tripoli the government has put a curfew
in place restaurants and cafes are
closed down education suspended social
gatherings band and movement between
cities restricted but the number of
kovat 19 is creeping upwards authorities
say they're doing what they can to
prevent further infections but some
municipalities are critical of the
government's measures to prevent a
bigger outbreak we've not received any
support from the government as of today
a budget has been dispersed by the
Central Bank but some municipalities
receive double their portions while
others receive nothing at all
communities are trying to fill the gaps
where they say the government has failed
this hospital in the city of Misrata has
been donated by a local businessman to
treat coronavirus patients and students
in the city are using 3d printers to
produce safety gear for medical workers
in Tripoli these young volunteers are
relying on donations to conduct
sanitization campaign they're cleaning
home for elderly as well as markets
banks and hospitals we do it out of our
humanitarian values we've also launched
campaigns to raise people's awareness
especially in slums and areas where
there are foreign wages the isolation of
this house for elderly people which has
natural ventilation makes it less
exposed to infection and the
vulnerability of the people living here
makes them a priority in the Sanitation
campaign run by the volunteers but
schools that have been turned into
makeshift camps for those displaced by
the war create a bigger risk of
infection the government is attributed
the lack of financial support to the oil
blockade by forces loyal to the warlord
halifa have
so in communities across the west of
Libya volunteers are doing what they can
to protect themselves and others from
the virus Mahmoud Abdul Wahid al Jazeera
Tripoli